This isn't your everyday article 13
video,
which unfortunately I know because I
wrote that script and had to throw it
out because of new changes that the EU
has made to their final proposal.
They rewarded article 13 to take every
enforceable part of the bill and all
they left is a giant pile of legal mush,
but before we get into all the changes
and what it means,
let's start with the basics.
Article 13 is part of a European
copyright reform that says that
copyrighted content has to be banned
upon upload by content hosting websites,
and in the original document.
This meant that all copyrighted content,
even copyright exceptions like parody,
fair dealing and educational videos
would be affected.
Needless to say,
the Internet was pretty angry and
worried about this
new law.
The current proposal of article 13 will
create large unintended consequences.
Article 13,
when the content is uploaded,
unless they know for sure who owns every
single part of it,
it would make sense for youtube to allow
for it to go up.
Most talented creatives you know who are
based in the EU will be banned from
Youtube.
We're all going to be banned was the
general consensus because it's true.
The first drafts of this law were
horrible,
but no one has spent much time talking
about the massive changes that this law
went through and what it means.
See,
when I started my original script,
this was a much different article 13,
it was 900 words,
eight sections,
and it talked far more specifically
about repercussions who would be
affected and how it would be
implemented,
but after months of discussion,
the EU has settled on a new version that
takes out every specific guideline and
leaves us with vague words like best
practices,
cooperation with rights holders,
large amounts appropriate and
proportionate.
You still get the feeling reading it
that it will have big implications for
copyright,
but there's nothing to build rules
around because nothing is clearly
defined for people like youtube or
facebook that will be affected by this
bill.
This thing turned from a law about
copyright enforcement to be more like an
announcement about a law about copyright
enforcement that someday in the future
will be further defined,
which as it turns out,
is kind of an EU strategy.
Making laws vague has its advantages,
but this is a huge problem for companies
outside of the EU and leaves us with a
question,
what should we do with vague laws?
What are the rules when you kept your
brain,
but the world is insane.
How the hail you,
Donna.
Let's start by talking about the U.
S which actually has laws about vague
laws in the US.
There's something called the vagueness
doctrine.
It says the criminal laws and sometimes
civil laws that aren't clear as to be
understandable by a man of common
intelligence are void or to put it
another way,
you can't be punished for breaking the
law.
You're not sure how to keep in the US.
There was a case of the FCC,
Verse Fox,
which illustrates how this works using
America's two favorite things,
bad words and nudity.
The FCC has these rules on broadcasting
that are called obscenity laws that say
what you can and cannot show on tv what
is appropriate and what is not.
The problem is that obscenity is an
incredibly difficult thing to define
because as we discussed in a previous
video,
what's obscene is always changing and
rather than take a stab at any ways and
make specific rules,
the FCC decided to be ambiguous.
They described what is inappropriate
using words like patently offensive by
contemporary community standards and
this all came to a head when during an
award show a couple people dropped f
bombs and later Fox aired partial nudity
as really,
really fucking brands.
So after these programs were aired,
FCC sent out a new ruling,
further defining they're vague obscenity
laws,
and then tried to hold Fox accountable
for breaking those new descriptions of
what obscenities look like.
The case of whether the FCC could find
Fox for breaking their newly defined
obscenity laws when all the way up to
the Supreme Court who eventually decided
that because Fox didn't know ahead of
time what constituted obscenity and
indecent anus,
the law was too vague to prosecute them.
That is how the US handles vagueness.
Now back to the EU.
They don't have an explicit vagueness
doctrine and this has caused a lot of
problems for American tech companies in
a similar way to how Fox almost got in
trouble for breaking rules that weren't
clearly defined.
Google did get in trouble in Europe for
the same reason.
They were reasonably fine for breaking
antitrust laws that ruled that they were
being anti competitive by pre installing
certain apps on their android devices.
The problem,
Google says they didn't know this was
anti competitive in their statement back
to the EU.
They argue that the EU has reason to
impose a fine rested on a novel legal
theory.
In conclusion,
they say there is no precedent for
characterize and Google's conduct as an
illegal abuse.
The rules must be knowable in advance,
but there aren't any vagueness laws in
Europe,
which means that that line of reasoning
didn't stop the EU from leveling of
$5,000,000,000
fine against Google all for violating a
rule that Google says they didn't know
at the time they were breaking.
This is the problem with vague laws.
Either you can't enforce them or the
enforcement seems arbitrary and unfair
and look,
there are compelling reasons to make
vague laws.
Judges get more latitude to interpret
with the changing times and if you can
give the member states the ability to
interpret those vague laws,
but many people say that that doesn't
outweigh the huge cons that come with
ambiguous legislation.
The number one problem being nobody
knows how to follow your rules and
example of this can be seen in another
EU law.
The general data protection regulation
has also been accused of being too
vague.
They defined personal data in such a way
that it could mean basically anything
which has left tech companies scrambling
to try to get into compliance with the
law.
They aren't sure they understand and
this is the EU playbook.
They declare really broad guidelines but
won't specifically define the rules of
the road.
Instead,
it's just left to these companies to
self define and the price of being wrong
is devastating to companies,
which is why everyone seems to be an
edge with what the EU will do next as
flex their regulatory muscles,
and this brings us back to article 13.
Nobody's quite sure what the EU means
when they say measures to ensure the
functioning of agreements with rights
holders or means when they say use of
effective content recognition
technologies shall be appropriate and
proportionate,
but what is clear is that article 13
means a lot more than it says because if
the first proposals of article 13 or any
indication of the longterm plan,
copyright exceptions,
memes and fair dealing will not be
protected or worse allowed at all in the
EU,
which threatens content creators like me
and many,
many,
many others.
If we look at the EU history of vague
law,
making it clear that Google,
facebook,
reddit,
all these tech companies and all these
youtubers have every reason to be very
scared over these new laws and protest
them.
Defiantly.
I think we all should not because
article 13 says all that much,
but because of what the EU can later say
it,
mental alarm,
this thing on this is a new mic so
you'll have to bear with me as we figure
out how to use it together.
Our sponsor today is Nord Vpn,
which is a very timely sponsored,
if you're going to be affected by
article 13 or any of these other wacky
Internet regulations that a lot of these
countries are pursuing.
A,
you need to be protected and you'll be
protected by a vpn.
I've used vpns when I did a study abroad
in college.
I went to cutter or Qatar,
however you prefer to say it,
and I had to use vpns all the time.
Um,
because the internet there is very
regulated.
Even a simple thing like watching a
football game,
you want to go to a local server,
just hop on your vpn and you get there.
But vpns go a lot further than just,
you know,
looking like you're from somewhere else.
A really,
they're about data privacy and this is a
big problem in our modern world.
People are getting better and better,
uh,
stealing your information,
especially if you like to go to coffee
shops or hotels or you're in airports a
lot.
This is a huge problem.
You're data is unprotected and the
things you're sending over the Internet
can be looked at,
can be stolen,
so that's something you want to protect
yourself from.
And one way to do that is a vpn.
The way I think about vpns is there kind
of like a seatbelt for the data world.
You don't need them very often,
but when you do you're really glad you
have them because they keep you from a
disaster.
And one of the really big cells of Nord
for me is the simplicity of use because
I've used vpns in the past and they're
very complicated and they're hard to set
up a nord is probably the simplest that
I've tried at least.
And I'm going to show you just how easy
it is,
like on something like your phone,
which I use all the time.
So let's say you're just browsing the
internet as you do and you realize
suddenly you're on public Wifi and your
data is out there for anybody.
Um,
what you're gonna want to do.
You go to North Vpn,
all you do,
press quick connect and boom,
it is that easy.
For me,
the simplicity is pretty much everything
because like I said,
it's like a seatbelt.
You want it there,
but you don't want it in your way.
So if you're thinking about getting a
vpn and you're a fan of the show,
you can go to north vpn.com/coffee
break to get 75 percent off,
three years and an extra month free.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash coffee
break.